chicago we got a mob  [Music]  chicago got a mob  he just jumped on my car  [Music]  division  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  probably 150 of them coming at me right  now  they're throwing shit like they're  [Applause]  trustworthy  two blocks  west  [Music]  theory advice  [Music]  i'm  [Music]  is  [Music]  there's two cars and there's too many of  these people  [Music]  they run in chicago  toward 90.  our fleeing westbound division  lock them in off of division  191  are you secure at this time  [Music]  yeah my uh  windshield shattered but  [Music]  division allston division austin  just bringing us to chicago  state car charles 181 advises  situation secure units responding on  a division in austin  [Applause]  i'll look through the description  anything uh  thank you  [Music]  charles and i believe i've seen uh was a  bunch of subjects jumping on his vehicle  [Music]  they just threw a  construction  kick in my car  [Music]  you